donald trump has denounced you my friend
donald trump i know condemns the proud
boys
white supremacists in fox news interview
after days of appearing to equivocate on
the matter
u.s leader says let me be clear i
condemn the kkk i condemn white
supremacists i condemn
proud boys i've said it many times let
me be clear again
i condemn the kkk trump said thursday
night referring to the clan i condemn
all white supremacists i condemn the
proud boys
referring to the extreme right
quasi-militia that has affiliations with
anti-semitism
and white supremacists the president
said his condemnation would be ignored
by the fake media
trump is the first president uh trump in
the first presidential debate which joe
biden failed to condemn white
supremacists
well i think it's it's actually i'm
gonna stop right there and say it's
incorrect he did say sure
three times although i wouldn't call it
a very strong denunciation i think it's
fair to point out trump has denounced
white supremacy numerous times and it's
kind of absurd to ask him over and over
again
but uh following this during the debate
he said proud boys
stand back and stand by i believe that's
was that the quote that was a quote so
we'll start with that
uh there were some messages that were
put out of i think it was like you joe
biggs
is uh joe biggs is a proud boy yes and
you guys were celebrating
of course we're celebrating well joe
didn't joe big say something uh
correct me if i'm wrong he said it's
he's essentially you know giving you the
green light to go
you know smash people up or something
like that so joe has been known to be
somebody that that says things he put he
got banned for saying like death to
antifa
and he's a he's a two-time purple heart
recipient doesn't mean that
yeah he could say things but uh
he's a firebrand and uh
when when you said actually before i get
into that when you said that quote
where's that what what news outlet was
that from that quoted the president on
saying the denounced thing
the one i'm reading right now yeah it's
the times of israel okay
i find it funny that they cut it off
there now the president unequivocally to
me
he denounced the proud boys right but
there was a quote that he said
that that's not the end quote of of what
he said he said i denounced the kkk i
denounced white supremacy i denounced
the proud boys
i don't know who they are but i
denounced that
was what the pro what the president said
and um
instantly i started getting calls from
the media and people were asking uh
um you know oh how do you feel about
the president denouncing you and as a
matter of fact like i sat back and i was
objective
about it and i'm like
a lot of people wanted me to say f the
president you know forget it he threw us
under the bus
or whatever
the fact is that we've never the proud
boys have never needed the president to
either avow or disavow or denounce
us we've always been who we are
unapologetic
about it and i think um
that should not change my standing it
shouldn't change
like how i feel about somebody or his
policy i didn't feel
there's a lot of times that i disagreed
with the president i disagreed with the
president on bump stocks
i disagreed with the president with the
dakota access pipeline
i disagreed with the president on
numerous things and just because i
disagree with him here because i don't
think he has all the facts or had all
the facts when he said that
when he said he denounced us it doesn't
change my support
for not only the president but
my values as a whole i'm not gonna jump
ship i'm not gonna go hey uh i'm pro-joe
biden now because the president
denounces i don't care about that
actually the guys didn't and i was
checking our chats right after the the
president was denouncing like man the
guys are gonna
these guys are like having a ball
they're like oh well we should change
our name instead of proud boys let's
call ourselves the
denounced boys and like these guys can
make a joke out of anything
they don't need they don't need somebody
we don't hold the president on a
pedestal we
we i i've been supporting the president
since day one
but that doesn't mean that we hold like
one person as an authoritarian figure
here this whole thing's all
an entire movement with different facets
so when the president said
let's go back now let's go back to to
the debate
the actual debate that the fact that we
got mentioned
at the first debate for us was exciting
i was with my
family i'm watching tv and they start
talking about portland i'm like no no
he's not going to say it he's not i'm
like on the edge of my seat
and then biden was the one that said it
and we were excited
right so i put a whole bunch of i put my
on my parlor post i went ahead and uh
and
i put standing by and biggs as always
and he actually corrected that and
cleared the record on what he said
um and we had fun with it
it took a little while for me for like
the the adrenaline to rush off
to really make uh for
for me to be become objective and say
well this isn't the president this isn't
an endorsement of the proud boys by the
president
it wasn't the president was asked a very
pointed question he was asked about
militias
he was asked about white supremacy and
when
biden stuck his nose in and said proud
boys the president
said and he was actually answering part
of chris wallace's question which was
tell these groups to stand down i don't
know why chris wallace thought that this
guy is like the president of
white supremacy and militias but he was
i think it was also
uh part of a gaffe that the president
had at the time and he said stand back
stand by
yeah now if i want to break that down
the stand back part
stand back like you said and i agree
with you we should stand back and let
the police do their job
right and we've stood back many times we
stood back
three days before that on saturday we
stood back and we let cops do their jobs
we had a cool little barbecue we had
like fireworks a big giant american flag
um and then the more controversial part
is to stand by
you know and everybody was like oh yeah
what did he mean by standpoint and the
way he said it stand back and stand by
yeah like like where's like some type of
like the media
picked it up like we're some type of
militia or
um like we're we're waiting and they
took it because it was it was
he's he's i guess they said that he
refused to say
if he would accept the election results
and they think that we're like a force
that's ready to pounce
right when that happens can i just point
out the absurdity having
seen proud boys and having seen say like
the oath keepers or three percenters or
like you know actual
militias or at least you know militia
type individuals
the absurdity of you know when you see
groups like the oath keepers are three
percenters they're wearing armor they've
got you know tactical gear they've got
rifles and the proud boys are wearing
those you know fred perry or whatever
it's fred perry as i was calling it it
is
polo shirts and there and they're you
know that's what i often say is
there's a lot of things the problems are
a lot of things you can criticize them
for a lot of things but if the proud
boys say they're having a rally and
and they have their rally and doesn't
show up then the proud boys get drunk
and they go home and nothing happens
yes if antifa shows up than fights and
it's usually antifa coming
and that's why that's where the earlier
criticism came in with like if you go to
antifa's place hold a rally
but i wanna i wanna i wanna ask you
what's your stance on dakota access
pipeline
um i disagreed with them because i
i believe that and i i think i even
disagree with people that were for
um against the dakota access pipeline
also
i think personally for as an individual
liberty i don't think that
a pipeline they should take away
property from
i don't i don't care if they were
indigenous people i don't care where
they were from to me that they were
americans
and they were they were taking away
property from americans to basically
give it to a corporation
is really what it was and to me that
that was completely wrong and that
shouldn't have happened
wow yeah so but does that would that put
you more in alignment with these
you know leftist protesters saying no
dapl
if that if that puts me in alignment
then by all means fine i see it as a
constitutional issue where
you're the government's coming in and
seizing property eminent domain
it sounds like you're anti-fascist
they have all these cool words i hate
that they're semantic arguments
they have they're like well you're
anti-antifa
you know what that means uh-huh no that
doesn't mean i'm a fascist
it's not and and liberals you know a
that's also like a really cool word it's
like liberty well
i got to clarify something i was told
that um
antifa just means anti-fascist so if you
oppose fascism
you are antifa is that correct you used
to yes now it's a group oh come on
don't label me right now no you're not
anti don't label me
you know where i'm going go ahead go
ahead spit it out do the proud boys
uh reject fascism yes i actually i just
said it like
15 minutes ago right denounce fascism
yeah is is
are the proud boys anti-fascist
i'm gonna can i cost so they could beep
it out
yes yes technically yes the proud boys
are anti-fascists
it's because well it's because we're
anti-anything
big government we're not anti-government
that's another thing that people got
confused
we're not anti-government we're for
minimal government
anti-authority i'm sorry i'm sorry but
based on joe biden's logic the proud
boys are an anti-fascist organization
well based on joe biden's logic he also
said that if you don't
vote for me you ain't black yeah that's
right and then he called me a white
supremacist
so to him to him look i i give him the
benefit of the doubt
to him it makes sense in his world
because i am not black
i i just can't you know uh i don't want
to say the guy's name but there's a very
high-profile
left-wing activist who is like a black
lives matter activist who's not actually
black oh yeah but he says he is and he
called me a neo-nazi
oh and i and the f so i i tweeted
everyone's like hitting me up they're
like did you see this dude's got a
million followers
he said tim poole is a white supremacist
and i was like the dude's wider than i
am so i just tweeted you know the dude's
wider than me it's
the weirdest thing i can't stand it i i
grew up uh
i grew up living in this world where you
know i was told
we won that fight race didn't matter the
civil rights martin luther king jr all
that good stuff discrimination it was
illegal
it still exists racism is still a
problem but we've won that fight and now
we have the law on our side
i grew up with people of a bunch of
different racial backgrounds
we even had some immigrants we had one
kid was from poland he was an immigrant
one kid you know hispanic spoke spanish
we had
some asian immigrants we had some people
who are various mixed race and it never
occurred to us we did have one kid who
would call everybody by their racial
slur
and that but it was like a south park
era thing you know
and so to us it was actually kind of
funny because we were all equally
insulted
but we i grew up thinking like none of
this actually matters and that took that
power away
and it wasn't until we started seeing
the rise of this left the
the identitarian intersectional uh
leftists
where all of a sudden now you have to
qualify you have to explain what your
race is
you have white people claiming they're
black and then insulting non-white
people as white supremacists
you've got white people calling candace
owens a black woman a white supremacist
calling a jewish man ben shapiro and a
nazi
it's just nothing seems to make sense
anymore and i don't know what their goal
is in this but to throw it back to joe
biden
like he said you know if you don't vote
for him you ain't black and then he said
you are a white supremacist i think when
um
when people become puritans right
because that's what we're fighting we're
we're fighting uh the when the revolu
american revolution started we're
fighting puritans where they were trying
to tax our sin
so they've become and now in 2020
they've become such
puritans that they're infighting like
you said like these and these blm groups
are ratting out the antifa groups
because they've made this like ecosystem
of like perfection
and a perfect example is there's a
researcher that researches proud boys
right i'm not going to mention her by
name and uh
she's done like all this cv paperwork
and and all this
research on the proud boys and how we're
fascists and stuff like that
and then come to find out that in her
application
um for school she was she put like she's
african-american and got like a
scholarship or something from there
and when her friends found out and said
and then she had been telling everybody
that she's like italian sicilian
right which the moors yeah
uh but they like hit her so hard that
they forced an apology out of her
and actually now her her research is
worthless
um so this puritan thing they eat each
other alive
and they have been eating each other
alive
and i think it's i think it's great
entertainment i think it's
uh some of these things you do have to
just sit back and just watch them
it's it's almost like a zombie
apocalypse when the zombies have finally
like eaten everybody there's no one left
to eat so they got to eat themselves
when cancer culture was coming after
everybody and they cancelled everybody
inside this are going after dead people
like uh i don't know if you saw bill
burr's snl monologue yeah
he's like they're trying to cancel john
wayne dude's been dead since like the
70s or something he's like well they got
to do something can you believe what he
said no he's not not in 70s but he was
like he was like can you believe what
john wayne said in 1970
it's like yeah that's what people used
to say yeah
it was it was a really really great
monologue in my opinion because he kind
of took the piss out of everybody
he he you know he gave it he insulted
everybody a little bit but he
specifically calls out cancel culture
and then got offensive with his comedy
you know he he did it perfectly to where
he wasn't directly
targeting the group but he kind of was
poking fun at certain groups
and they start calling for his
cancellation of course but i
feel like we've already come to this
point where i mean they've canceled all
they can cancel
i mean what are they gonna do they
cannot there is nothing that you can
cancel me on
absolutely nothing yes you can't cancel
me on anything anymore
i've been canceled look listen this is
your band this might take an hour for me
to actually process all of these
but i'm kidding but i've been canceled
off of
the big three social media platforms and
multiple times i'm on my
like 19th twitter account i just made
another one today
um paypal
airbnb i never used airbnb by the way
huh i just use it to browse properties
and they ban me for hate speech i have
the screenshot of the email coinbase
which is crypto coinbase commerce
uh chase bank my bank i worked with
project veritas and we uncovered that
chase bank
deleted my account because and i was
doing business with them even before
they were chase banks i actually
actually covered that i got leaked an
email
from somebody who worked at the bank
that they they terminated
the the so i got to be careful here it's
been a while since i covered this story
but i was sent
a bunch of private information i
released only a little bit of it and it
seemed to me
that they had banned you out of a fear
of bad public relations
bad pr yes and so that was it and uh
and that's what they do they make a pr
nightmare for these big companies they
get like on their twitter and they
hammer their twitter until and they
probably don't want to cancel me but
they're like
we don't want the pr nightmare in there
they take me off
but um i was the craziest one
was and it was
like two weeks ago they banned me off
mailchimp
right which is normal because mailchimp
does ban conservatives all the time from
sending emails but
there was i had a very unique situation
so i was thinking about getting
mailchimp
so i added their extension their website
extension to my website
right so i never got around to
creating an account i just had the
extension and you know you have to buy
you have to put like your license number
in so it works or whatever
and um i just had it on my website and
antifa went ahead
and saw the like the css code on my
website that i had mailchimp and they
they started banging on mailchimp store
hey you got to d platform the fascist
well mailchimp responded and said that
they have cancelled my account
for a terms of service violation i never
had a mailchimp account
like they virtue signaled in order to
in order to like get the mob to calm
down
and the same thing happened with paypal
wait wait they they claimed that they
banned your account
yes and you didn't have one i didn't
have one that's a false statement of
fact
yeah and they put it on a tweet that's
interesting i think that that might be
clear-cut defamation oh yeah
well i'm i'm working on a couple of uh
i'm working on a couple of things right
now
um mailchimp is probably there but it's
at the bottom of the barrel when we're
thinking about things but
we're gonna i'm gonna go after we we
and i are gonna go after all these
corporations
you can't
you can't donate to the proud boys you
can't just go to our website and be like
oh i want to give them a hundred dollars
we've
we're getting we're pretty much i think
that we're going to keep it that way
for a very long time we're self-funded
um no matter where i go i don't i make
sure that nobody pays for my stuff so
nobody says hey well i paid for this or
i paid for that
and that's the same thing with all proud
boys um
but like these lawsuits
since we're self-funded like people are
like oh well why didn't you why didn't
you sue chase why didn't you sue this or
why didn't you sue that
well we don't have the money to do it
right now but
i think joe biden has given us an
opening i think joe biden has given us
an opening to go ahead and push these
what is your website proudboysusa.com
and 1776.shop well you
you can't donate to proud boys but we
sell merchandise
through 1776.shop and that's like the
only way that you could
uh but you can't like directly donate
you can't like that money goes nowhere
do you sell that shirt yeah actually yes
i actually printed this shirt because i
was uh
to get on this podcast and um but yeah
i'll have that on there too as of
tomorrow
but i uh
we're on one of our main tenants is
glorify the entrepreneur
and um and we believe that
if if we're gonna get
money out of something we're gonna sell
something we're gonna sell a product
we're going to sell a service or things
like that and that's that's one of the
main reasons why i joined the pride boys
is the entrepreneurship
i i believe that um
and killer mike is the one that has this
t-shirt line and i love the saying on it
it says
kill your masters right and already
like obviously the government's
overreaching or whatever
but another master that everybody has in
their life
is their boss and they feel like you
should start by getting a job and
learning the ropes but i think
that you should want to build something
for yourself
that's why i joined i joined because i
was already that person
and i felt like i needed to strengthen
and i think iron sharpens iron
i learned a lot from just hanging around
the guys at the bar
so here's my here's my like one last
question before i go to super chats
with gavin's history of bombastic
threatening or offensive things he said
and he's gone way over the line
and with the history of the proud boys
and the early on mistakes
why why keep using the name that's been
smeared and tainted and has
has this passed in these associations
why not just do
something different make a different
group get rid of all the all these
things
explicitly because why would we want to
play their game
why would we want to play on their
battlefields and be like oh well
um they say that this name is bad so
let's change it
that to me is bending a knee that to me
is like bending to the mob
that has labeled us all these things
that have been false
like i said before we're not everybody's
cup of tea but this isn't about
everybody it's about
like us and us is
as a brotherhood we put
our god if you're if you're a religious
man
our family and our country and then
comes a brotherhood as an auxiliary
thing
but that doesn't mean that any of those
are are something that we're
willing to sacrifice just just to be
just to have a pr stunt
we don't care it doesn't matter if the
president
if the president denounces us a million
times
if the mob comes after us it doesn't
matter how many articles that people
write about us we're always
we've built this we've built this
organic thing that hasn't been done
before many groups have failed they have
too much of a militant structure we're a
very loose structure we're very fun
the only way that you can that this
thing can die is if we suck the oxygen
out of the room
all right and we take out all the fun
that it has
we have fun with each other and i don't
see that dying off anytime
soon i was thinking it's kind of like an
example of of brotherhood is one way you
put it but like giving men meaning it
doesn't have to be men really but
giving people meaning in in today's
culture we talk you were talking earlier
about how how great it would be if you
could highlight the conversations that
people have across the aisle like
at a rally when the people on the from
antifa speak with the people from proud
boys and they communicate
like jordan peterson had a great viral
video where he was communicating with
students that disagreed with them and
they were yelling
and he was just calmly communicating for
10 minutes and
he also is focused on giving people
meaning so
i see this kind of this through line of
and i think that antifa
those people are finding meaning in what
they're doing and
that we're lacking that in culture these
days i don't know why
maybe too much social media but why
there's why meaning has gone astray
for young people or for for even adults
maybe and that this is a type of thing
that gives people meaning well so so
i'll tell you i think i don't think
gavin
uh i think in the literal sense he
founded the proud boys
but i think he actually found the proud
boys and what i mean by that is
to him it was a joke i mean i saw i saw
when he went on rogan and he said it was
just some stupid thing from a musical
and he was making fun of like oh yeah
you can be a proud boy too
but i think what he did was he lit the
torch for
some kind of fraternity young men
no no no core group no ideology no
mission no purpose
and so in a way there's a similarity
between that and say antifa
in that i believe antifa is the left's
version of this that
you have a bunch of people with no
purpose student debt no mission no goal
in life they have no idea what they're
doing
and so they're indoctrinated into
extremist communism
you know revolution destruction rage
violence
and then gavin gave space to a bunch of
young men to punch each other while
naming breakfast cereals and getting
drunk
and that's all a lot of these dudes
wanted was just hang out feel masculine
and
you know crack jokes and just not have
to worry too much
so i feel like whatever it is you guys
represent
could have been something else it could
have been called something else it could
have been founded by somebody else
and gavin just happened to be there at
the right time and that actually
ultimately leads to a lot of the the
you know the ease i'll call them
vulnerabilities very obvious things that
are
critiqued and denounced and and denied
and things like that in the media but
that's why i asked like you know why not
do something different
i understand your answer but just to you
know make my point is
you've got a group of men who you say
don't want fascism don't want
authoritarianism
you want to kind of do your thing you're
proud of your country and that could be
a regular old drinking club that could
escape the political connotations of
what the proud boy's
name carries i agree
but the thing is
we feel like celebrating
stuff is what it started right uh and
the name is actually
it's a good conversation starter you
know like imagine he thought of like
this really gnarly name like the
the patriots of of of death
you know or some i don't know i don't
know what a cool name would be but like
it's a conversa it's a cool conversation
starter and it isn't about the name
it isn't about um
the cereals it isn't about that it's
about like the dude next to you
um and just getting out of the house
it's a family thing
right the biggest thing about proud boys
is the pro family part of it
it's it's making like i said making
better men and i think that we have
and i think we've done that in a funny
way and i think
that we've left an imprint in history we
have done something
monumental a small group of guys that
started out as a joke
have made this monumental change
and whether people like to see it as a
positive change or a negative change
that's up to them
i'm not i'm not the arbiter of that or
not but i know that i love my guys
i know that i have uh these guys are
hard-working americans these guys
are carpenters uh plumbers police
officers
uh elected officials i mean they come
from all walks of life
and you know what they don't deserve
they don't deserve the crap that they
get from the media
but you know what at the same time if
they get it
they turn around and they make the best
of it and that's that's why i love this
i think whatever we get in history
in the future it's going to be real
weird because the media is so broken
i think wikipedia is the easiest example
of how
the media's fracturing and and dissolve
disillusion i guess is uh going to
affect how we keep record
of historical events you have on
wikipedia
they will use any blog by a 22 year old
intern
who wrote some nonsense with no with no
sources and they'll consider it fact
and that makes wikipedia completely
you know i'll put it this way the
scientific articles yeah they have
scientific and academic journals
but now we're getting to a point where
the pages don't even link together
properly because one definition on one
page is a leftist one versus a right
wing one and it's all breaking
apart as we have these like two
different world views
now you know coming into focus the
leftist worldview 1619 project
and then the traditional american
historical world view
they can't co-exist and so when those
two different groups are writing
articles on wikipedia
it makes no sense so you know ultimately
what ends up happening is you'll get
you know vox.com progressive outlet
will hire some college kid who you know
a better example would be the daily
beast
the daily beast is a couple of writers
that have uh
straight up made things up and that's on
the record now
historical records should have made up
stuff and i've actually reached out to
them for comment and they just ignore it
so if you've got these news outlets
writing fake news garbage and straight
up saying
do not do an interview with the proud
boys then what is the record
of history going to be if they
specifically avoid
figuring out who people are what they
believe and what they're doing
they're writing history they're
basically right in front of our eyes
they're writing history
and it makes me question a lot of things
in the past
but that doesn't mean that we allow them
to win
it doesn't mean that we should let them
do it though
every retraction again the unlike you
i've sent
the daily beast many retractions and
they they just ignore my emails
but it's fine with me i i don't care i
don't mean the daily beast i don't need
facebook i don't need instagram i don't
need
i don't need any of that to to i'm an
activist well so i don't need
i don't need none of that to organize
maybe a lot of people do
i don't but what's happening now is
they're banning people from banks like
you
and from other technological services
there's conversations about how we uh
we're gonna be moving towards
in the future a car less society where
individuals don't own cars cars are
self-driving and you have an app where
you
will say here's where i need to go and
the car will come to your house you'll
get in and it'll drive itself
and we have that already we have we have
a service where a driver can come and
pick you up
yeah so if you get banned from all these
services
and they're all private then it's only a
matter of time before you're
locked out as it were human rights
transportation finance access to the
internet and the use of its services
if you're banned from you know a bunch
of these
services and they eventually become the
only way to do things
then you're out they've cut you out of
society this is why i've always been pro
i'm i'm in favor of the government
regulating these big tech these big
corporations it's always been
it's but it's always been the liberals
who have been in favor of regulating
corporations when they start infringing
upon the comments until daddy trump
came in now they're cheering for it yep
that's a nightmare dystopia man
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you